time to get to bed Johnny well I got
home at 7 a.m. we had to we had two
buddies of mine flew me home but we had
to wait for two hours and 24 other
planes took off before before we did
private jets
yeah yeah but nonetheless I'm home how
would you compare this game 7 with any
other one that you saw and certainly you
were involved in one of the great ones a
lot of people look at that game 7 as the
greatest game 7 with Minnesota and the
Braves yeah it was it was a weird game 7
the reason I said I was because the game
was well in hand for the Chicago Cubs I
mean a five run lead and you're trying
to figure out how to Cleveland get back
in it you know this is a game where
Hendrix has got it well in hand and and
and cruising I mean and then to have him
come out when he did those two runs with
two outs on a wild pitch you could sense
the Cleveland not only felt they had a
heartbeat but they were going to be in a
situation where they're going to see
Chapman and they're gonna see him for
multiple innings again possibly and all
ultimately that again two outs I could
have never seen a game in a series were
two outs nobody on and so many things
had happened it started in Game one with
Lester two outs nobody on he get to get
to run around a stolen base and two
walks and field hit and hits batsman and
that game went the Cleveland way and and
that kind of was the theme of the series
you know don't take anything for granted
but also how hard it is to get three
outs in an inning and you know I I don't
know why I mean I personally don't know
why some of the starters have been
yanked as quickly as they did and we've
come to find out it's the first World
Series ever that no starter pitched more
than six innings on either team and
it caught up in so many different ways
when you have to keep going to the well
so many ways to not trust other guys and
it turned into a classic but it really
in my mind should have never gotten
there but it did and and drama and and
storylines certainly played out and it
was crazy if the Cubs had launched what
would we be talking about today well
much like any other game seven we'll be
talking about a certain strategy and
certain moves I think again from the
onset when when you start squeezing outs
and squeezing scenarios to either steel
outs or it started really with Game six
for me I mean Hendricks two outs
questionable call gets a walk and they
take them out and we're forced to see
Chapman a lot earlier than you want to
and and and yeah I get it I mean the
Cubs had to win that game but you know
the starter has a role in it and it's
been taken away lately just by the
philosophy of baseball you know gotta go
to the bullpen gotta go to your bullets
got to use this guy we're almost such a
copycat League and catering to the
questions that a manager has to ask or
answer that he's asked I think that's
what you're seeing and so use the guy
who's your best guy don't be left
without using your guy it started almost
with the wild card game with Baltimore
and then we full come full circle with
Miller throwing more pitches and more
innings she ever did and Chapman doing
the same thing and by the last time each
guy was hittable each guy was normal
when they were unhittable used in the
form that gave them the best chance to
be successful he's John Smoltz joining
us Dan Patrick show but I also wonder if
Joe Maddon looked at what Terry Francona
was doing with his bullpen and decided
to do the same with her oldest Chapman
or do you think he had planned out but I
mean in Game six when the game got out
of hand it was an easier game to manage
for Terry Francona he's saving all his
bullets for Game seven was Joe couldn't
and
think when you line it up it was a
flooring race - who can get the lead
you know Kluger was not as good as he
has been and how can you blame him three
starts in a series first time ever he's
not struck out one guy so the custom
things within each series that they
played that adjusted and made
adjustments to get back in the series
and win it they did in each one and I
give them credit
you know they stretched it out they used
more of their weapons and balance that
they had that Cleveland just didn't have
the luxury of happened yeah they had
more depth there and I thought that that
came to fruition the rain delay felt
like it was a godsend for the Cubs that
allowed them to hit the reset button
what did you think at the time yeah it's
weird because I thought it would have
gone the other way you know I'd have
thought it would have created more
pressure on them and more time to think
of oh my gosh we had this but it didn't
kind of went the other way and and reset
the focus the momentum of Cleveland and
this you know Shaw was out there and in
rhythm and certainly at home you love
your chances anytime you can get to a
ninth inning tied yet alone an extra
inning game so Cleveland had this
relentless will that their manager
basically has for them and and you know
they they certainly had every reason to
maybe not fold up the tents but
understandably face Chapman with three
run deficit and needing four outs I mean
in the end Maddon got what he wanted he
got to pitch Chapman four outs with a
three-run lead the problem is he had to
go to him so much the last two and three
games that it ultimately caught up you
pointed out you don't want to throw
something down and in to Davis and then
Chapman so throw something down and in
and then he hits a home run there
I couldn't understand for the life of me
that that kind of pitch certainly and I
didn't think he could hit it out but you
know that that's what was I don't know
if he felt comfortable with his fastball
thought more you know felt more
comfortable with his slider can you
explain that pitch what what happened is
look
he was fatigued and when you're fatigued
you lose location Oh anything over the
strike zone and up nobody has a chance
against Chapman yeah and he was trying
to what I think forced the velocity when
he never has to force velocity and when
you're when you're a little bit rundown
you lose your location and it's the one
out of 12 spots that you can't go
through and it's the one out of whatever
the odds are that Davis had a chance to
drop the barrel of the bat and as a
pitcher and I've always said this having
been through so many of those games
you've got to be aware of that you got a
you got to understand the moment cannot
get away from you and you got to focus
on the one thing you can't give the guy
and it just happens I mean I don't blame
look Chapman was almost heroic in the
sense that this guy battled through
three straight games of pitches and in
quantities never gone through and and so
you're out there grinding away and it
just happened to be the one area that he
couldn't afford to to throw it to and
and I got applauded Davis for being
ready I mean you got to get a little
lucky and that's what I said you've got
to get a little lucky against a guy like
this it throws that hard you hope it's
there you trust it's gonna be there and
you react Congrats John I thought it was
really well done I thought I don't know
how nervous you were but I thought you
were as good as the series was so well
done
I appreciate that thanks a lot get some
sleep thank you John that's John Smoltz
MLB on Fox the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience